[Music]
sk
gaming have been obliterated
destroyed deconstructed and frankly
embarrassed by schalke today
this is a 3-0 many failed to understand
how schalke even got into this position
i know that it was through guilius's
blood
sweat and tears that they were able to
make this miracle
a reality gillius is the alpha
and the omegas gillius is everything
that shalka has needed to bring
this miracle to life four thousand hp
three thousand hp two and a half
thousand
there is no room for doubt
so europe you have to tell me
do you believe in the miracle
hey everyone before we get into shulka's
story i want to make sure you know about
mastercard's cliques of the decade
a countdown of the best plays from the
last 10 years of international league of
legends competition
so make sure to follow at
mastercardnexus on twitter to see who
made the list
alright now on to the rest of our story
shulk's summer split got off to a
pitiful start
the losses were piling up the team
seemed done
for but there should be a close up they
just need to escort the minions in
dreams desperately trying to hold on
hoping for his outplay moment but
the most he can hope for at this point
is to survive he's flashed over the wall
to get to safety but here comes the bear
nothing left for the poor high noon
thresh excel fantastic
game from start to finish you that was
mad disrespectful special i respect it
flash in the shall cut no fear now no
sex
as they are yet to find a win halfway
through the split
their record was abysmal they were
firmly in last place
and any chances to make the playoffs
looked bleak
but shulka's biggest weakness also
turned out to be their greatest strength
and i also think like quite a few teams
for a long time didn't
expect us to be strong they would
probably go into the match day and think
oh yeah it's just
the team that's like two in ten who
cares you know and what those teams
didn't know
is that shulker had a secret weapon four
thousand hp
three thousand hp two and a half
thousand oh he got started
pulled inside flashdad goes back in
you are a god amongst men
bow to your lord in god gileas
one does not steal a baron from him
gillian started the summer as a member
of schalke's academy roster
after a disappointing performance in the
spring split
but in the midst of this terrible losing
streak schalke called up gilius
bringing him on to the main roster to
replace lurox
and he turned out to be exactly what
shulkin needed
no nemesis doesn't have flash he used it
under the nexus house before and dreams
goes in
neo's gonna get dead charges here on the
back when the ghillie is on a killing
spree and neon still alive
try to dive in the exhaust but here's
the hero's entrance and because i had to
cleanse the qss and try and get out of
there but he's going to be the last one
standing is reckless versus the world
and i've said that so many times before
but reckless knows
there is no way he gets out of this one
let it be
known you may beat shaoka eight times
but no one
beats shaoka nullifier nine times in a
row
huge win for shalka to end their first
half
of the season gilius has been around for
a long
time for a while he was a perennial
challenger player before
eventually making his way into the big
leagues he'd played for sk at worlds
unicorns of love elements vitality and
even schalke in the ulcs
and even hopped over to na for a stint
on e-united in the north american
challenger league but every single one
of his results was
pretty much the same mediocre the few
times he helped teams re-qualify for the
eu lcs he was booted
off the lineup for someone else and in
the major leagues he rarely stood out
fnatic should know that this is
happening they get a blue trinket okay
and dropping brockton needs to make his
way in immediately jacksonville trying
to find the kazakhstan
but he's done that oh god the
turn the burn he gets deleted but that
is exactly what fnatic wanted
but for whatever reason when schalke
called up gilius from their academy
roster
a new player was born gilias was
no more god gillias was born
the roster move turned out to be the
beginning of something great
gillian's passion and drive gave the
rest of the team the confidence they so
desperately needed you know when we were
say zero and six
um there's a lot of
lack of you know trust even in yourself
not just like your teammates or
the coaching staff or whatever like is
happening but also in yourself
and i felt that
i think you could see it even from an
outside the way they played and they
they were making mistakes they were so
so weird to see whereas now
they've gained so much trust and belief
in both their teammates and themselves
sean couldn't just bounce back from
their losing streak they became a real
threat for
any team trying to secure a spot at
worlds
only the second time at this split
dreams once again
with the hook and shoulder have done it
they found their second win
against the other finalists from spring
splits the shuffle in
they won it all give him all five give
him the ace and give him the second wing
of summer that was entertaining people
in the game dreams gets caught he does
indeed
very good does he wait around hillary
thinks he does but it's a trade of one
for one neon manages to take out nemesis
and now fnatic
are running for the hills ripple cannot
get away from the cc
glacial prisons available for gillian
said he's not even gonna need it
emperor's divide locked south bay inside
the jungle
and it was hillar saying that started
the fight but shelka finished it still
alive but then go for it go the classic
shanton flash to finish the deal lebron
goes down dream's gonna take that one
neon now stepping forward came to get
one shot by melissa the flash out to
safety
heel now coming in that's it nexus
exposed shalka
the miracle run alive they will have to
step
over the body of vitality to make it
happen but they're more than happy to do
so
[Music]
against all odds schalke were suddenly
on the cusp of making playoffs
something that seemed absolutely
impossible just a few short weeks before
honestly we are writing this this so4
miracle run
if it goes to like the world's finals
and hey we're fighting this wave you
know like dream big might as well go
hard
so many things have to line up for
schalke to make it to playoffs
the results of the sk game the xl game
and this misfits vitality game are vital
for schalke and i'll keep you up to date
on all of them as the day goes on but we
are at ocean soul
mad lines must secure the smite but
gillies has beaten shadow every single
time
and not only are shelka on the verge of
making the miracle run
a real possibility there's zero what's
it gonna be
is on the verge of picking up a spot the
soul is it's julius again
does not lose those mad lions are inside
the pits they're chasing they've lost
one
they're stuck they're done there's no
ways this is the game for shelka
they've won the fight they're gonna get
the ace they're not going to lose a
single
person and they've got enough time to
push down the base shulker have
decimated and destroyed the mad lions in
the in the pit in the dragon pit they
get the soul gillian's lands a smite
and they crush mad lions one more time
from the worst
team in the lec to a legitimate playoffs
contender shulka have smashed
every single team they've faced in the
last few weeks of this split
and they beat mad lions down and they
beat them badly i never
stopped believing in this team i said
they are going to make playoffs and they
did everything in their power to do it
and
just like that fnatic will be locked
into playoffs shalka
as well and on the other side
oh has to feel good obviously one of the
most incredible stories we've seen
in the lec probably in league of legends
to go from 110
to qualifying for playoffs so many
things had to go right not just
performance we
had to be this close in the league for
the entire season for that team to even
have a shot but once they made playoffs
there was a new question could shulka
make it all the way to worlds
he's level six two level six the
teleports coming down from genex as well
i believe
first blood picked up by crown shot
instantly killed
is limited by up attacking this oh
aberdeen anticipates it manages to set
up
three kills for shelka there's a reason
people
are saying the name faker doggie and it
is because he is coming in clutch
but they're ready to go doing it oh
those coming in from the bottom lane
this is the flank that he wants oh it's
going to be huge
five man hemoplague he doesn't go in we
put
two early dreams the trench lines there
it is
there's the hemoplague oh no wait for
the perfect moment that's gonna pop not
be able to do
a lot more though oh he does it again
what a fantastic play
sk gaming has been obliterated
destroyed deconstructed and frankly
embarrassed by schalke today
this is a 3 0 10
games in a row and a question i ask
everybody is how good are shelka
how far will this miracle run go
after dumpstering sk gaming 3-0 the only
team standing between shulka and worlds
was mad alliance and they were willing
to give it their all
in terms of the ultimate goal this team
will really keep going
all the way until they are that they
absolutely have no chance anymore even
even when this team
is zero two uh in like your best five
series i'm 100 convinced that this team
will
give it their absolute down quite so
easily and gillian's the man they tried
to start a fight on is now turning it
right back against them but odawam name
to the backside
cars he's still alive trying to run for
his life it's a messy fight neon still
coming through
neon still alive neon remains up the
double kill for abu dhabi and that is
disaster for the mad lions
that is all they have left one more shot
but it will not matter
triple kill for abu dhabi and the game
for chalk and no fear
such impatience that came from the mad
lions right there shadow
who's moving around they tried to force
the engagement they didn't get the one
that they want and that was all she
wrote it is gonna be game one for
schalke
the momentum continues the series
started off promising for schalke
but it didn't end that way but they
still like to fight you they still
trying to make plays they're gonna try
to do that again here with humanoid in
the top lane
hold back though we'll fire him out to
safety now gets to buy a bit more time
moving forward into the t-piece and
fancy forward coming through human
rights
taking this shot as long as possible
he's going to pull him back but now
aroma is in the midst of everyone but
it's still just a 2v4
maybe not what they're looking for but
humanoid still manages to make it out he
goes golden he cancels out the ultimate
guys are going to set forward to try to
bodybug humanoid
is still alive now that's a houdini you
could be proud of shadow
moving in with kaiser as well on the
backside meanwhile roman fishing for a
fight buying just a little bit more time
neon
not doing the damage necessary to get
anything done abu dhabi running for the
hills the double kill for shadow
and meanwhile here comes the ash on the
bottom side karzi
looking to play clean up one volley one
slow that's all it's going to take to
run down the rest of schalke as karzy
runs forward here and odawamne the last
man standing he will not find a knockout
he's now trying to retreat unstoppable
use kaiser coming in but abu dhabi is
going to be able to careful the perfect
cc here in avodah you're going to get
shut down no he pushed him
he wants to finish off shadow but he
can't do it gilly is now moving in he's
kept the dream alive
the rest of the team now needs to back
off though because the rome on the back
side chow guard just gonna get picked
to pieces in comes the ash gilly is
trying to finish the kill desperately
but shadow he's just prancing around
he can't be stopped the double kill
coming through
it's over kill mad lions they deserve to
go to worlds they're going to knock out
shulka
right at the finish and the most
important thing about being a top team
in europe is being
clutch and on the day in the best of
five mad lions were clutch
there is no room for the miracle run any
longer the mad lions are here they've
proven themselves to europe and now they
can prove themselves to the world
so in the end after their incredible
miracle run
shulka didn't make it to worlds but they
faced odds that looked insurmountable
they did a complete 180 and half a split
from the worst team in the lec to
legitimate worlds contenders
the miracle run was a miracle run when
they made playoffs it was a miracle run
when they threw out in the first round
and it's still a miracle run even if
they lost here it was an incredible
finish to the season for shalka no fear
no doubt
and as disappointing as that loss was
there is something that
everyone can learn from their recovery
no matter how hopeless
a situation looks it's always possible
to turn things around
like when i started screaming with you
guys you guys were so like
it's already over like just get it over
with every day
i mean and then after the display you
know yeah it's just chilling
i mean you can't really be like have
total motivation you just have to play
and just play zero though
there was some sparks and with
everything they've learned this split
for schalke there's always next year
there's like a little thing of fluff
stuck
onto the like railing of my balcony and
it looks like somebody is in the balcony
like
down two floors and across from me and
they're like waving at me and it's
really distracting because it's like
right behind the camera
and it looks like someone's waving but
there's nobody there it's just like a
weird thing of sloth
might even just be a spider web i can't
really tell
this is very interesting i'm sure